yeah I don't think this was a good
material to wear on the show holy moly I
know here we go
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Niall Horan you
can catch him as a first time coach on
NBC's hit show The Voice which returns
for season 23 March 7th and more
exciting news we have brand new music
the single which is Lovely by the way is
called Heaven as well as his newly
announced album the show which is set to
drop on June 8th but available for
pre-order now Niall Horan welcome to the
show thank you it's great to be here
um I'm very nervous Sean well I feel
like this has been kind of years in the
making you know finally we're pushed in
the room together what's going through
your head as you prepare to take on the
wings of death oh well I love watching
the show I'll let you know how I feel
doing it
um I'm a huge fan I love what you've
done and it's a it's just a genius
concept and I've always wanted to do it
and everyone was like blown away when I
told them that I was doing it and I'm
I'm seeing it in front of me and it's
making me scared and people were walking
around with gloves on bringing in milk
and water I'm like ah
I've already started sweating let's go
[Music]
okay right here we go
hmm
[Music]
classic
you're teasing me
so as you mentioned in your intro it's
your first time releasing new solo music
in nearly three years announcing the
name for your third album the show and
then just days ago dropping a music
video for the lead single heaven I'm
always curious how an artist decides on
a lead single especially after a
prolonged Hiatus like what was it about
heaven that screamed to you that this is
the song that fan should hear first
I think it's one of those songs that the
concept sums up what you're going to
hear from the record it's a it's a life
big thought song
um and it also gives like everything
sonically
um you know production wise everything
is kind of all in in heaven so when you
it's a good tee up for what you're going
to get from the rest of the record it's
a good sing-along when we wrote the song
we were having a great time anyone who
played it to since kind of sings along
with sings along with the melody and um
yeah so it's just kind of a everyone
agreed that this should be the first
single
[Music]
right let's do it
what's that flavor maybe you're picking
up like the ranch it could be just
straight Ranch that you're picking up
yeah
it's kind of like a pickly oh yeah yeah
pickle vibe to it maybe yeah I like that
one there we go do I get to keep all of
these actually you totally do it yeah we
back them all up for you and give them
to you on your way out amazing right I I
do tend to lean for a hot sauce with
most
dinners I have or lunches or whatever oh
okay cool boss
I don't want to be that guy I've seen
too many people come on here and be like
I'm gonna nail this and then they're
crying
spitting into buckets and
yeah that was that one was nice here we
go
your lead single Heaven it has these
gear shifts that are so Dynamic so
Sublime within them from a songwriting
perspective what's the key to an
effective bridge in your opinion oh
um do you know what I've been doing a
lot recently doing the pre again doing
the doing doing the pre-chorus again
um but yeah Bridges is just like
sometimes it's like a tension and
release kind of thing you've got a lot
of information in Verse Chorus Verse
Chorus and then it's just a complete
departure to to get away to the bridge
and give them some new information in
the story I'm always trying to find if
you can't find a good Bridge the trick
is to go back to do the pre again do the
pre-chorus again that's that yeah if you
can't get a good Bridge you get to a
certain point at the end of the second
chorus and you go for a new thing new
chords new Melody and it doesn't work
got the old pretty backup
[Music]
yeah he looks dangerous this guy yeah
for sure all right here we go here we go
this is
tasty
what's oh it's got It's got it yeah it's
got a little after kick you know yeah
exactly I think sometimes these sauces
they hear you compliment them and then
bang slap in the face slap in the face
that's what you get for underestimating
me
um
wow okay now it's starting to heat up I
get what you mean okay I'm still okay
number three the fact that it tipped me
at number three
me too though if it makes you feel any
better all right we're in the same boat
here we're in the same boat
so your new role as a coach on NBC's The
Voice is a true full circle moment going
from the audition stage where your
career began to now your role of coach
and Mentor from your spinning chair
Throne you strike me as a really nice
guy how do you navigate the role that
rejection plays in a music competition
show like The Voice yeah I'll be honest
but that's the part I've struggled with
um because I know what it's like to be
16 and stood on a stage
I'm looking at some famous dude that's
got um your future in his hands the easy
part is pressing the red button spinning
the chair saying how you like someone
but when you spend its chair turns
around and you're not with them how do
you give them that rejection feedback
um and that's where that's where I've
struggled with it but it's it's full
circle stuff and it's um
gotta say I've really really enjoyed it
apart from the rejection I really
enjoyed it
I would Nile the coach of today judge's
own 2010 audition I wouldn't have turned
it
was a right place right time
um no I've I've I don't think I want to
turn for myself put it that way a turn
for me now I've learned a lot
I've been around the block a couple of
times uh which is a lot can be said for
someone who's 29 but um
yeah I I turned now I wouldn't have
turned that that's the truth
[Music]
okay here we go
and I think it almost goes down a shift
you know we're going down the gear here
don't speak too soon though don't speak
too soon we're going back to the
pre-chorus
exactly no Bridge just yet yeah
don't need that complete departure until
the bomb it looks so scary the bomb but
don't take yourself out yet don't take
yourself good stuff I've made it to four
and I haven't puke or anything yeah they
can't take that away from you now can't
take that away from yeah how did it go
well I got past four
without snots running down my face so
they can't take that away from you right
so while music is your first love I know
that you have a passion for golf that
began as a kid in childhood staying up
late so you could watch the masters from
Ireland and then here you are all these
years later playing some of the best
golf courses in the world with the
single digit handicap when you think
back on all the pro-ams and celebrity
tournaments you've played to date what
has been your crowning golf achievement
wow that's a that's a good question I
made uh I played Riviera in the Genesis
open uh with my good friend Justin Rose
about five years ago
and I wasn't very good at the time but
somehow I made five real-life birdies on
the back nine uh which is I've never
done ever since and I probably never do
again to make five birdies in nine holes
but I don't know where it came from and
we ended up winning the proa
so it was uh that was that was a good
golfing achievement do you have a go-to
swing thought
um
I've about five or six uh Tempo is my
number one tempo yeah like keep it slow
I always hear like my friend Justin
always says that pretend you're like
winding up a like a Jack In The Box
slow back quick through kinetic energy
apparently
and then do you have a 19th Hole
tradition
uh about six points against us there we
go yeah that's the way to do it I'll do
it that's the way to do it six points
again it's in an Uber home leave the car
in the parking lot guys all right good
advice are you ready to move on here to
the halfway point you're doing great by
the way here we go so this next one is
the Brooklyn Deli ghost pepper sauce
Brooklyn that oh I've seen this one
before
[Music]
I like that
well here it comes yeah Slow Burn
leaves kind of uh a trail behind you
know it's long too it's not one of those
quick Snappy oh holy moly I wasn't
expecting that
all right now we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
gram where we do a deep dive in our
guest Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so we'll
pull the picture up over here on the
monitor you just tell us the bigger
story right
ah there he is what's the most Scottish
thing about Lewis Capaldi and what would
he say is the most Irish thing about you
everything is Scottish about Louis
there's nothing else about him uh he's
the most Scottish man I've ever met
um
his ability to hold his accent no matter
where he goes no matter who he's
speaking to and not give two flying F's
uh as to if they can understand him or
not that's the most Scottish thing ever
well I've kind of spent so much time in
America that over the years I've
realized maybe I should slow down
um because they actually don't
understand what I'm saying like people
will look at me with like like I've got
10 heads
um Lewis's ability to not care is the
his most Scottish thing and he would he
I think he's actually talking faster to
Americans
to see how much he can annoy
first time uh myself and Lewis met Sean
we were in we were in a bar and like it
was a club kind of vibe in L.A yeah yeah
yeah and uh West Hollywood nightclub
Vibe yeah through and through I don't
know why we were there but we were there
anyway and um Sean you come over and uh
to say hello and I was like
I don't give a [__] what anyone says man
this is the most Starstruck I've ever
been
and he was deadly serious can I take
your number I want to come on the show
he was cracking me up he was like well
two of us I was like this is sick you're
cracking me up too but you know what
it's nice to get that kind of a hero's
welcome yeah I'm walking into a dark
cavernous nightclub yes right now where
they're going around it's all sorts
going on in there and then we see you
like it's uh yeah we're both huge fans
oh yeah what a night and you know what
we've gotten you in here now now we just
have to get Louis yeah
it's easy
thank you
all right here we go
no afterburn we're good you think you're
good yeah oh do I think I'm good
hopefully we're good hopefully we're
good do I think I'm good or are you
telling me that I'm expecting should be
expecting something you know sometimes
this one hits a little bit later
I was nervous coming in here and I
should still be nervous but I don't want
to be that guy that like I want I want
to see myself her spray and like not
throwing everywhere else yeah it's
better it's better TV
do you have a most thrilling memory from
the pitch reflecting back on your
multiple soccerite appearances
I remember one time I played a game at
uh Old Trafford Manchester United
Stadium the first time I ever played it
and I've got bad knees so I was only
going to play like 15-20 minutes anyway
but I remember walking onto the pitch
and the first person that passed me the
ball was Ronaldinho
and the second person that passed me the
ball was kafu it was I bought to those
guys that won a World Cup and I'm just
looking around the pitch and it's just
like legend legend World Cup winner
Champions League winner Premier League
winner and me with the book with the
skinny legs and the bucket he needs
um soccer head is just like it's the
best it's like our dream and we get to
play with Legends like that it's such a
cool thing
I can't stop staring at the bomb right
like it Telltale Hearts you a little bit
right
all right I haven't touched the milk yet
I've noticed that I've noticed that by
the way clock that all right are you
ready to move on here to Sauce number
seven I guess I am so this next one
dreams of calypso okay
foreign
[Music]
my way around here I'm afraid to like go
and get the little bits in case they're
spicy right yeah and let's like it
activates something yeah kick something
loose
all right oh that's got a look at that
kick that's a prolonged one it took a
while to get there and then it just goes
boom exactly we have a little bit of
like a cumulative effect I think you
know I feel like after we're not seven
we're just layering one on to the next
over here you know
so I've heard you talk about the
influence that the 70s has on you bands
like the eagles Fleetwood Mac but I'm
curious how much of your songwriting
instincts do you simply attribute to
Growing Up in Ireland and being steeped
in such a rich tradition of words
yeah I've always kind of grown up on
that and grown up on singing Irish
singer songwriters like Damien Rice and
things like that so he's obviously
played a big part in what I do excuse me
kicking in now excuse them off that's
really rude isn't it but I'm sure
yeah you have a real Long Leash real
long news
but um how I naturally write would have
a Celtic influence and then lyrics yeah
lead into that kind of story telling
that we are kind of known for I'm not
James Joyce but you know
if you were to walk into a country pub
and somebody gave you an acoustic guitar
is there a go-to song that you'd go to
first to win the room over
oh
that's a great question but you can't go
wrong with the fields of athenry that's
a big Irish kind of like uh big Irish
Pub Anthem
um anywhere that's anywhere that's heard
in Ireland that gets sung along too
usually when I go into a bar unless they
were handed to me in the first drink or
two
don't come near me after a few
everyone's like come on sing us a song
I'm like no okay I can't I shouldn't
because it'd be a disaster and people
have phones these days right right I
don't want to be seen all over this
containment yeah
is there an Irish slang maybe
specifically Connie westmeath that you
can't shake no matter how many spins
around the world you take
that's such a good question I need a
second on that one
foreign
like I'm cheering you on go on go on
well on that topic
this next Wing is to bomb Beyond
Insanity my message now go on
go on oh you did you take that one up
priorities I can't be look at the color
of it compared to the rest of them I
mean
I'm trying to find my side there's much
I actually got the shakes right I've
been nervous about this for about seven
years
[Music]
oh oh no no here it comes
and this is just there's the
perspiration that Brian Cranston was
talking about nothing can prepare you
for it
and that you were talking about you know
you're like I want this to kick in let's
get it going
that good TV you were asking for like
it was just in the mouths before now
it's everywhere yeah yeah I don't think
this was a good material to wear on the
show holy moly I know here we go I know
I'm going into
Sean
is a dangerous Society this
I want to see myself first
not throwing everywhere
yeah it's better TV
wow
I know please tell me it's downhill from
here please so it'll probably continue
to grow on us just a little bit really
right once this kind of mushroom cloud
of the bomb clears on the other side of
it it's all downhill it's all downhill
but the next I don't know 45 seconds to
a minute and a half
we're in the storm we're in the storm
Nile
careful careful
there you go I already made the mistake
they're almost almost
had your One Direction band mate Liam
Payne on the show he told this story
about how he playfully trashed your car
then took a picture of yeah and then
posted it to the internet but never
blurred out the license plate what do
you remember about the Fallout of having
your car tracked by fans for a time I
remember just going why did you do that
um it's outside the studio I was in
recording the vocal holy moly I know I
know
no comment your honor
um
it's got me shaking that one it was
outside the studio I was inside doing a
vocal and I came back out and him and
Louis had like
put garden chairs all over the car it
was like mops
buckets about 10 rolls of toilet rolled
and he just took a picture and put it on
the internet
and there was my license plate all over
the Internet no not even a fear of
blurring it out
[Music]
I really get it now folks this is not as
easy as it looks I've always you know
you know those people it's like
I'm like it I've seen it before I've
watched the show a thousand times you
kind of there is an element of or that
spicy but also is it right are they
acting are they doing it right it's
natural right when you're watching the
show you're like oh well yeah yeah and
then you end up in the sea different
story it's just a step
the edges of my lips and the tip of my
tongue are just on fire now for the rest
of the day I hope I hope not
okay please say this is easy
right yep but
no nowhere near not like the last one
not like the last one
it's just adding to what the bomb
did yeah sometimes it can kind of like
wake the bomb up again you know yeah
yeah when the bums starts to go to sleep
Undertaker in the coffin coming up Taco
Vibes comes in and goes
kind of outdoor amphitheaters that you
find in the United States what makes a
place like Red Rocks your favorite stage
to perform on yeah I love the
amphitheaters um nothing better than
going on stage when the sun's setting
and on the last tour we sold it out and
I was like Blown Away one of the better
nights of My Life
um
you've got all you can see is all these
beautiful rocks and an ocean of people
just a really really really cool
experience I do I enjoy the
amphitheaters in general you feel like
you're on tour when you're playing the
amphitheaters
all right Nyle
I made it
[Music]
I need to do it with two hands in case
yeah there you go get a bit aggressive
Slow Hands
[Laughter]
there you go that's perfect that's
perfect yeah happy with that I'm happy
with that
I can't believe we're at number 10 I
never thought it was
right Cheers Cheers thanks for having me
of course thanks for coming in
[Music]
body in the wings
long overdue
whoa I know
[Music]
the dab yeah kind of fell off the wing
and hit the back of my throat straight
away
that happens oh I've been there I know
well that's not far off the bomb maybe
it's because I think accumulation but
and I think it might have been just the
way in which it attacked you you know
plus it was just a bullseye Landing yeah
nothing fun about that nothing fun about
that but the worst is over we're in the
clear and before we get to this final
question I have to give you some context
all right so back in 2017 Liam said in
his interview that you're his favorite
person to grab a cheeky beer with okay
and back in 2017 when that episode was
being worked on by one of our editors
Mari okay she was pregnant at the time
thinking about baby names lots of things
bouncing around in her head and no joke
just the way that he said cheeky beer
with Niall that's what inspired her to
actually name her firstborn son Niall
all right that I thought you were going
to say she was going to call the bear
the baby Cheeky beer
also a good name
that baby
half years old okay and we're gonna go
to the monitor because Nile and Mari
final Wing 10 question for you that is
crazy by the way
so I want you to meet Nyle
oh my god
um and he's cute like my favorite song
is uh here can you tell him what your
favorite song is
um
yeah her spirit song is what makes you
beautiful and while I do love that song
um we've heard it quite a few times now
so I was just wondering if you can
recommend another song for a mom in a
car
um that would be played many times over
and over again for a five-year-old okay
love you
Niall needs a new Nile song I can't
believe that that's amazing I knew that
Nile became a popular name at one point
but um
I didn't see the way that yeah it
coalesced with hot ones to actually you
know yeah
um
okay great question
um he likes What Makes You Beautiful uh
Heaven by Niall Horan
you can stream it now you heard that
Nile go check it out grab your mom's
credit card
and look at you yeah I caught that right
yeah go again do that again all right
you know what I gotta nail the Dismount
and look at you Niall Horan taking on
the wings of death living to tell the
tale now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
thank you for watching I've got my new
song Heaven that's out right now I've
got my album called the show it's coming
out June 9th and I hope you enjoy it and
I'll see you some more soon
[Applause]
I believe in it holy crap
oh Liberty listen where are we going
just
[Music]
you know what's so good I like I I
didn't he wasn't even looking at you and
I knew what to do because I watched that
many times
wow
hot ones fans breaking news the three
and one boneless bites challenge is back
for a limited time you can put your
taste buds to the test against some of
our most iconic flavors the classic Los
Calientes and the peak of heat Apollo
but don't fret hot ones fans even when
the three in one challenge leaves the
freezer aisle you can still pick up your
favorite flavor of hot ones boneless
bites visit hotoneschallenge.com for
more information on products and to find
a store near you because it's time to
bring the Heat home